magnus mcduck inspired by magnus mcduck
on twitch
do not take mr cube fanatic's advice
here this is terrible advice
h2 and h7 is where it's at oh we got
game
game game time
oh man it's been too long
it has been too long
all right i should have thrown my h-pawn
down there when h pawns attack
all righty
this is a weak in square g5 i'm looking
to kill the knight and then drop on d5
he's a pin knight
he's not going to move is he
throw my knight in there
and
what next
e3 bishop to e2 i might one day
sacrifice here
come on move your pawns
this is a pinned piece that's attacked
with the pun
he better not move and if he doesn't i'm
just taking him
i mean it'd be good if he does move so
he's gone
don't want to take that pawn i want a
queen trade queen side castle here
queen's off
plenty of time i'm actually up on time
here no need to castle keep my king in
the center
let's negate this bishop first
did this game start with
a time difference
we're gonna see i'm gonna have to pay
closer attention to that
pawn push next
29 seconds
not sure why i did that ooh
anything
four seconds anything at this point
no time
why are they all of a sudden moving so
fast
it's not moving so fast there we go back
to tournament
okay the the points aren't out of
control
that's a good sign and i am starting
with less time
okay good so i think everything is in in
effect here whoa that was almost the
adobe flash gambit
okay let's hit this guy
and let's uh make life difficult for
their dark square bishop to get out
actually he's kind of stuck
he is stuck
and the queens may be gonna be in a pin
at some point
what am i doing why wasn't i moving just
then
h2
where's the weakness
light square
weakness this is no good i'm dropping
stuff
it's no good
all right their bishops back to life
here
hit the queen i'm on the bishop
i'm on the bishop
lateral movement
okay
take like this
get my bishop here why didn't i take
that pawn
stand these light squares
i want to smash through on that square
this is check
okay okay this is this is falling what's
the time situation
let's go here i have plenty of time no i
don't 17 seconds
this is not plenty of time
okay i need to do better here
there that's a good home for the bishop
check
check
he's a past pawn he should get running
gotta go here 6.6
that's not a lot
huh
um last on time i got to do time burners
and stuff
oh i'm down on time oh
whoa how does somebody have 16
oh man i gotta come back now i gotta go
chasing
okay
stay focused oh that one that's so
painful
oh man
i had that i thought i had a free piece
a free piece and their bishop was dead
ah
all right let's
let's try for something over here in the
h file h4
knight g5
let's let's shoot four what's my queen
doing over here on the king's side
gonna give me this file
it's probably fine to take that knight
hit here
i'm gonna kick that knight
get him out of there
where's the knight going he has to go
to not so great square
all right i should probably get castled
soon
if that oh if that bishop moves i could
push there's some checks
where's the rook going he's
close to trapped he's got to take this
pawn so now the h file is going to open
up
hmm
queen takes
okay this file has opened up i'm just
doing this to clear the way for queen
coming over here
um
let's take this first
and then this
this isn't really mate though i want to
keep the queens on the board
let's try this again bishop here maybe
let's try it again
queen trade oh i think that was
definitely a mouse slip
definitely a mouse slip
they resigned back to tournament 32
oh i think it's set up wrong
32 points after five games
oh
man
what was wrong i think it should have
not been linear with the points win
i think that's the that was a problem
yeah i think that's a problem
uh what can you do
eventually
i'll figure it out
32 points after five games
can't have that
upon push i go here i'm weakening the
square though
this is not good
night here is gonna be awesome
oh boy
oh boy this is scary
very very scary
um
don't really want to do that
my dark square bishop is stupid
he's a very stupid piece
wow
okay fortunately i have on knight b6
rook takes truck i'm on the queen
this knight is ready to land a fork oh
boy
big trouble i should take this night out
while i had the chance
oh
they got a block with the knight there
here
no i feel like i'll be i got to take
that knight out do i really think i
could play this position
with uh
with uh that knight on the board
absolutely not
absolutely not
all right
what is my rook gonna do
tethered to the defense of a pawn
position you never want to be in
never
okay here check
6.8 seconds is not good
gotta
throw in time burners
oh why didn't i just take that guy
time burners are all i have 44 i have
11.
okay
gambit
except
hmm okay
bishop g2
let's get all my pawns up here let's try
to be a bit more aggressive here unpin
my knight not happening so fast
all right he's got to go back
let's go for this h5
i guess we'll take here
looking for a push and then a sacrifice
on g5
okay let's throw my knight in there and
then
i should have captured what does that
even do
what does that even do
queen trade i just can't help it
knight right here is going to be awesome
it's the pawn in here
i don't want to i don't want to move my
knight just yet
a4
or the king up there and discover checks
let's take this now
that's a fork
i'm getting at b7 after one of the moves
i'm on the knight or on the rook
like back here
no okay let's take here
oops how we doing time down on time
again
it's just how it works
it's just how it works
push
rook trade i'll take it and i'm going to
hunt down that rook or that night
night knight to e6
watch out for tricky stuff
no forks
please no forks
it's so dangerous
knights are so dangerous look there was
another fork there i hit that knight
with the fork how does he like it
landing forks to all
chess players all the time that night
there's an easier way to do this
which way you go i'm gonna go here then
finally
wow you have to be so delicate with that
crazy night around
okay barry
is barry gonna move
oh no this is
this is fool's mate barry
no not quite
not quite it's not going for that oh
that's a free night though
that is a free night
what is going on
barry is on instant move
instant move barry
take the bishop and then promote
where is the mate
next no
now it is no
we're almost there
we're almost there the queen has to
block and now it's mate
barry throws the farm
that's his strategy 29.
hmm okay 74 i think having a very good
win streak is going to be very important
i think you gain more points if there's
a win streak something
f4
knight f3 open up the f file
pin the knight
if he takes i'm going to win a piece
um okay weaknesses light square
weaknesses i want a knight right here
right now
knight on f5
this is ready to collapse
i like my knight too much i want to give
him up so easily
queen takes pawn
let's check
now there's some dangerous stuff
happening here
let's push because i have a fork next
where's the mate
this should be made soon somehow look up
and over
here and then here
still fishy pawn push
they might resign
now they see
it let's try this
i didn't have to go in this direction
definitely didn't have to go in this
direction
queen there
stop it i don't want to clean trade
i'm fishing for stuff now it's just not
there nine seconds
and the alarms are going off
nine seconds and alarms are going off
never ever a good sign now i want a
queen trade now that i'm sensing serious
danger this really backfired a real lot
oh
throwing that sneaky move
not working
why'd i go with the pun
oh stalemate
they have five seconds
it's not steel mate that's made i'm down
on time as well oh
man
it's mike
it's a mic thing ah why did i have to go
in some
why'd i have to sack a piece i didn't
have to do that ah
okay
i think i have to i restart too with my
points
oh that's no good
i have to start back at one or two
oh
bishop d6
bishop back
and then queen d6
oh that's very weakening isn't it
take here and then take on d4
i should have never let that happen
never ever ever whoa why wasn't he taken
not sure queen takes knight was there
castle 30 seconds
let's push and then push again
could have taken that rook
take him now
and push where
take twice here
let's check
make sure that night's out of there
we're even on time
ah
okay this is all falling anything
let's see how many points i get for this
how many
too little
too little
where's the mate
somewhere
there's me
this is taking forever
this is taking forever
kings and chat king takes pawn they're
down on time 40. how many points did i
get there
oh 15 we're at the halfway point
can i even
go to uh i gotta get in the top ten
fishing for top 10 land i think i have
to try like scholars mate stuff
crazy scholars mate this is the
anti-scholars mate though
pawn on e6
stops all threats against
f7
yeah they're going for tricky stuff
against my king
hmm
knight here
all right
let's back up
queen d2 let's give this guy a kick
let's try that i am weakening this dark
square diagonal a real lot
and spending a lot of
what does that do
very little
i should get my rook around here i'm
gonna have to go with part ways with my
light square bishop i guess
yeah this knight's gonna drop in here
it's going to be a very nice home
what am i doing
right here this is going to be a nice
square
oh i'm on the same diagonal as that
bishop
oh boy
20
seconds
let's back up i'll probably just push
sack upon here
see if they give up their light square
bishop probably a good thing
of course i run away scared hang on
let's get to this square
i could have taken on this
this point here let's defend that 11
seconds where is my time
oh no rook some rook move why did i do
that there's rook takes pawn
whoa how do i get out of it that's not
the good way to do it what am i doing
that was ugliest
ugly ugliness
time burners is all i ever have
it's all i ever have
anything they're down on time i never
ever want to look at that game again
ever
oh man
that was
ugly town oh my goodness was that ugly
town
i never want to look at that game again
never
discovered checks throwing my king into
the line of fire
my goodness
oh regroup here
regroup
oh okay i could defend that
okay
you could do it you could do it throw
your knight on f6 get castle don't get
hit with the fork don't throw your king
on the same diagonal
as your opponent's bishop
oh man knight takes
e4 queen b6
rook d8 let's start with this why didn't
i take that pawn let's throw the knight
in a pin
bishop here pins first
on push
now we'll take that guy
i have a time lead
whoa
hmm
oh let's do this this is a little
sensitive here
whoa
all right
why don't i see that i'm not seeing
things clearly
not seeing things clearly
watch out for mates it's just trade
let's just trade here we go
the dust has settled
the dust has definitely settled and i
have a time edge
beautiful
love time edges
came towards the center and i just boxed
out i could grab that pun
grab them now
they're down on time back to tournament
70. one ooh 19th
162 161 my goodness
cheap tricks
it's not happening
let's try c3 here
all right
and take my pawn get my knight here
bishop here look for a d5 break get
castled
get castled here
hanging pawn structure
my rook on e1
i don't want to trade
let's keep this knight around i have a
space advantage back up
take here
queen d3
pawn push
on push again
right here i have that covered
got these light squares
let's do this can i rook on this square
pawn push
h4 knight g5
some weaknesses over here
hmm
queen trade oh why'd i do that i'm just
dropping that pawn now
that wasn't good
oh i'm dropping a rook this is ugly
we discovered check they didn't go for
that though rook here and i'm setting up
discover tricks
not with that move though okay there we
go
23 seconds i have a time edge rook
check knight here with the fork
another fork here
let's take upon
where are the forks oh that's very very
helpful
i needed that
i definitely needed that
in here
i have a time edge as well
okay
got this i know i i know i know how to
win this one
back to tournament 201
177 i'm in 18th how much time is left
oh
oh here we go
i need to try fishing pull tricks just
to get in top 10 land
just for top 10.
can i score a quick one
we're gonna see
knight f6 knight g4
hang on still available
now
king side
i'll still try it maybe
yeah okay let's try for b2
bishop here i push
dark square weaknesses
hit that knight
um let's give a check
if the knight moves there might be mate
here unless he goes to a4
bishop here i take the knight and then
mate on b2
yeah
i guess we're going to have that
29 seconds
gotta go quicker
my rook is pinned
g5 is probably good move this pawn's
falling but
not now
okay what about this
the king goes to this uh b file this
move is strong now let's castle
rook here and then pawn push
okay now okay he's not trapped
another pawn push
and maybe i could double up and then
take on this square after a capture
like right now i'm threatening it
okay i'm on the night
and my knight wants to enter the scene
now i'm on this square to what three
times no
no
okay they don't have any time back to
term and 221 108.
oh man
okay
accept accept accept
um
pre-move no i didn't catch him in a
pre-move
oh no
there's adobe
flash that was the adobe flash right
there
i don't know if it came up on the screen
i don't think it does anymore but it
happened just then
definitely happened all right let's try
for b4 b5
stop this break this bishop's kind of
dead
let's make sure he stays there now
there's no bishop h5
there's no tricks here
let's enter the position
control these squares
um let's take here
he's still kind of dead i should give
this bishop a kick
let's try oh rook takes knight in some
variations could be good
all right let's get here
why'd i go in this direction
let's give a check
not sure what that's even doing
my position is getting broken down about
rook coming over here
and this one here
over here now i'm gonna take my knight
sec
probably gonna sack that
that's so fast hang on i want to keep my
tricky night around
bound to be a fork
bound to be a fork
throw him in the corner he loves being
in the corner
whoa
not sure why he went like that
i didn't move
time burners all of a sudden
oh that's up there with the ugly games
oh it just turns ugly
it just turns ugly when it's a very
limited time
oh one of these
one of these huh
all righty
that's a check
all right i am gonna gain a tempo
against that bishop
chase this knight around
throw the knight in a pin bishop here i
go here
and then
do something dangerous hopefully
dark square bishop is gone
let's remove this knight so then he's uh
back to being a problem
crash through right now
where are you gonna castle stay on this
diagonal no king sight castling no soup
for you
that's the no soup for you move rook
here is gonna be dangerous isn't it
queen in the center
queen f2
let's not even let that king run so fast
hang on
watch out for h2
h7
i would have screamed
i definitely would have screamed
definitely
all right
and this pawn is passed my opponent is
definitely going to remind me of that
queen trade
that's painful
gonna go like this
it feels like they could uh promote okay
i gotta do this whoa they don't have
very much time
not a lot of time
luckily
they don't have enough time here
i could do anything moves
anything type of moves back to
tournament i guess yeah i did have a lot
of pressure early on but that was yet
another ugly one less than three minutes
remain and i am way off this uh
tournament should not be as lin uh
linear a linear setting i think that
that's what it's on i think it should be
none
okay
spin the knight go for this little dance
here knight d2 knight d2 c4 rookie one
back up there's light square weaknesses
now
i'm gonna go with the structural change
my knight is very good on c4
um
step up and push whoa
it's an interesting move i want to keep
my knight position
oh that's a free queen
yes back to tournament
168 i'm in 15th
okay
even if i i think even if i won no
there's something with those streaks i
had zero
not not good streaks in this game at all
many speed bumps
many
too many
alright let's go here
play aggressive throw pieces in your
opponent's territory
have them flinch there goes my light
square bishop my good bishop
i guess try to get in here they could be
getting into this square
focus on this one here
i feel like i need some breathing space
with this rook coming over here
that's why i played f5
um
let's see is that knight really going to
give himself up
maybe now
he's going to drop into here no
i think he was better placed here i
don't care about losing that pawn
not at all my knight is pinned
let's take here and then here
okay i'm there to defend now
oh i had this check the queen blocked
though
past pawn i should just push him
push the pass pawn i have the square
covered push again
even if he's sack there
um
secure my rook for right now
take here
stay out of checks
here's a check but it's not really
leading to much after that okay now the
queens are off
take here
no stalemate
here here
and then here is good enough back to
tournament
168 oh the term is completed 20th oh
yeah i had to make that adjustment 321
there's
it's something with uh the setting
with uh
linear or none i believe that's what it
is i wasn't looking at any of the stuff
that you guys are saying in the chat you
probably already know
all right let me scroll down here good
games oh
magnus
mcduck get the queen chase her away from
the bishop hit the bishop again i'm on
the queen i'm on the queen the queen is
dead dead queen
no no no no no no no no
what did i just do
oh no